énorme
formidable exemplaire
qui sont formidables
je m'appelle André
en céphalopathie
à la naissance disons et il y avait pas
de docteur
tous les matins je viens c'est pour
aider mes parents parce que moi je
travaille pas et les autres soeurs qui
travaillent sont il peut pas quand mes
parents peuvent le faire le boulot que
ils font
je sais pas
tous les jours
faut jamais cacher il faut aimer les
handicapés il faut aimer les vieux faut
aimer les jeunes toutes parce que tout
en a besoin
lorsque Léonard ici Monsieur et Madame
Grondin on va décider de récupérer
c'est un quotidien
qui font s'enraciner sans se plaindre
même s'ils sont malades ils se lève
quand même ils vont s'occuper de lui
félicitations merci je sais plus parfois
j'ai plus de mots tellement c'était la
chaleur de mon cœur